[Music]
let's go to daisy in the city of angels
what's up daisy
hi how are you i'm so good how are you
um little well thanks for having me of
course what's up
okay so
here we go um about a year ago my mom
passed away oh my gosh what happened
she got sick it was cold related but
then underlying diseases and
yeah it just happened really quick in
two days like she was gone daisy i'm so
sorry
yeah and
um so she was
fostering um on the process in the
process to adopt my three nieces okay um
they're all under the age of seven so
seven four and three
and um they're my brother's daughters he
he and their mom are both addicts so
they're not in the picture
um so when that happened um
my sister and i we were leaving the same
home as my nieces and my mom so we took
over
but i'm 26 and my sister is 30.
talk right into the phone daisy yeah um
yeah so she has her own son and
i'm 26 without kids so you know we kind
of didn't know what to do we spent four
months with them
um
then their mom's family from out of
state called and
they fought for them in court they took
my nieces with them
out of state and um
they were out there for about four
months we went out there to visit my
nieces you know i miss them like crazy
and you know i basically grew up with
them and um
suddenly
i get a call i'm at work and i get a
call from social services and they're
like well you know your nieces are back
to la and
they're in the foster care system with
you know random families what happened
i guess their family in texas wasn't
able to care for them anymore because
they had like their own kids and they
didn't really prepare they just kind of
suddenly took them away man
yeah so then
yeah and you know i love them so as soon
as i heard that i was like i need to get
i need to get on it and i need to fight
for them like
meaning the world to me um
and aside from that i've been with my
boyfriend for a long time and you know
we're starting our life together we're
eventually planning on having our own
kids and all that but
i've always been hesitant because i
kind of never wanted kids i always felt
like i
you know i do so much with my nieces and
all of that and i just didn't want to be
i don't know it's just a lot so what's
your what's your question yeah how can i
help oh sounds like a mess well
my
now that i'm taking custody of them in
two weeks oh wow so you filed for
custody and you got it
yeah so you're about to be a mom of a
seven and a four and a what
three-year-old
dang gina
wow
good for you okay so it's it's happening
it's happening and um
my boyfriend is not on board
oh
daisy daisy daisy
okay so how can i help
i i feel like you know he i love him he
means the world to me i always come my
whole entire life with him so
now that i've made this choice and i've
decided to take it on take on my nieces
and
you know like try to
you know provide a better life for them
um
is
how do i get over the fact that he may
not be in my life anymore just because
of this choice that i've had what a
heartbreaking and great question
great question
all right so i'm just going to tell you
the truth all the way through is that
cool
yeah
what you've done is one of the most
extraordinary
noble sacrificial things i've ever heard
of
and
it's going to be very very very hard
yeah
the
statistics tell me
that you are gonna have to be real clear
and real precise in your next steps
or you'll end up in poverty with three
young kids
yeah right and you know this do you have
a degree do you have a trade what do you
do
yeah i'm an accountant ah
some okay so you're ahead of the game
i hope so no you are um what's your
annual income
um about 65 000. daisy's getting it
what does knucklehead make what's your
boyfriend make and i just called
knucklehead he's probably an awesome guy
yeah he makes about um 90 000. dang gina
y'all are crushing okay getting it okay
so
um
dang
so here's here's the
he feels like you chose them over him
yes not them with him
right
and
have you all sat down and had that
conversation this isn't about them
versus you this is about what's right
yes and he knows that that's the right
choice but he feels like he he can't be
a part of it because he's not ready and
he's used to having a certain lifestyle
and now he knows that's going to change
and so now it flips back on you which
sounds like he's choosing lifestyle over
the woman that he's going to spend the
rest of his life with
yes
if that's the case
if that's truly the case and i'm not
certain that it is
then you have like the matrix dodged a
bullet
and i'm so glad you dodged it
because this would have come up in two
years five years 10 years 15 years
if he is interested in a lifestyle over
you
that comes up somehow in the wash it
always does
the other side of it is you deserve
somebody who is all in on you
and when you're faced with a hey my
mom's got cancer she's gotta move in
with us cool we're gonna figure this out
hey my brother is an addict and he's
known this all along your boyfriend
and that these kids are floating back
and forth and they their heartbeats with
yours is how you feel about them and
there's always this chance lingering
and so here we are and he's making a
choice
there is no easy simple
heartbreak free path through this
there's just not
and this happens when if you had gotten
pregnant this might have happened
like i'm not i'm not ready for that you
know what i mean yeah yeah i've thought
about exactly that i was like well he's
not with me on this i mean what else
what else what if i would have gotten
pregnant and something's wrong with the
child and
he's not there with me that's right
that's what i'm saying you may have
dodged a bullet and you may have
become a single mom with three kids
seven and under and his brain exploded
which i want to give him some grace on
that too
yeah okay
here's the path through this
you have set some things into motion
again
so noble so brave so incredible this is
family legacy shifting stuff
at your funeral there will be hundreds
of people talking about the time you
stepped up when nobody would and gave
these three kids life
okay what you're doing is generational
and it's gonna come at a cost okay so i
won't i just want to put that out there
there's no way to keep what was and to
do the right thing in this situation
hear what i'm saying
yeah i understand so here we are we've
done the right thing and it might cost
us and it may cost us but it's not going
to be because we did the right thing
it's going to be because other people
don't want to be a part of our new world
and they have that right and that breaks
our heart and that makes us weep and
that makes us sad and that doesn't mean
that we didn't do the right thing
okay
that doesn't
help in the middle of the night when
you're super lonely and he's not taking
your calls or you've decided not to call
anymore
yeah and that doesn't help when there's
a your three-year-old that needs a
diaper change and a seven-year-old
crying and running around because he
misses mom and dad and grandma it
doesn't in this the third placement in
three years right there's gonna be
challenges on this journey
so much easier
if that guy would call you today and be
like you know what i'm i'm i'm crazy
about you we're getting married this
weekend at the jp and i'm i'm ride or
die
you know what i mean because then you
double and a half your income you've got
a guy who loves you is going to be there
for the kids and unfortunately he said
i'm not in for this ride
so what has to happen sooner rather than
later and you're not going to want to
have this conversation because you're
not going to really want to know the
answer you'll want to know one of the
answers but not the other one
you're going to have to sit down with
them because these kids come in two
weeks
and you need to have the conversation
are you in or are you out
because if you are out i'm not going to
bring another adult in these kids lives
that's going to leave on them
and he might say i'm out
and that will be
that would be devastating right
yeah hello have you had that that
thought run through your head you've
looped through that before haven't you
okay so where do you land on it
i just wouldn't want him to be in and
out of my life and then seeing
that i'm allowing him in and out of my
life because of them only for them to
believe themselves you're so good you're
so good to yourself into those kids
do you have one or two girlfriends that
can walk through this with you yes i do
okay
so here's your next steps number one
rally your girlfriends
and what i mean by rally them i mean get
everybody three five seven of them
cousins i don't care friends whatever
and say
kids are coming in two weeks
i need somebody with kids to help me
baby proof my house oh by the way do you
and this guy live together
we have for the past four years but i
just got my own place okay
so are y'all already breaking up do you
feel it happening
kind of yeah
is it kind of or is is it over
well it's
it's still the same between us but then
when it's anything
we bring up like my nieces at all he's
kind of like well that's kind of that's
your life and i have my life so when you
say it's just the same that means you'll
still sleep together and you'll still go
to dinner together
yeah but y'all are broken up
i i don't know it kind of
feels like we're in the middle of
something or like we're kind of avoiding
the topic sometimes there you go so you
gotta have that conversation
okay
you're going to start drowning soon if
you're not already
yeah i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
all right so three girlfriends four
girlfriends y'all get together
and i want y'all to come up with a
strategy for the next two to three
months
how are we gonna get kids to school
um how are we gonna get kids home how
are we gonna get kids like where do they
go to school how do we even have
conversations with teachers all that
kind of stuff
get a couple of friends who already have
kids they're gonna walk you through what
happens
i want you to make up a fake morning
routine
everybody gets up at the same time we do
breakfast like this we go to the park on
saturdays at least just for give these
kids some routine and give you some
routine okay right
otherwise you're gonna be it's like a
fire hose
i got two kids that have been with me
for a long time and i don't even know
what day it is some days okay i'm
telling you
so
the second thing you gotta do
is have this hard hard conversation
i think if i look at behavior as a
language you've moved out
he's told you pretty clearly that's your
life now which means that's not my life
which means
we're dragging out the physical stuff
here we're dragging out the last like
ellipsis of connection but this
run its course
and you are hoping praying fingers
crossing rubbing
the genie in a bottle lamps right
that he's gonna call you and be like
dude i'm crazy i'm sorry
um i he he might not he probably won't
i know
i hate that okay you just said it out
loud
does that
wash over your body
yeah i i've kind of noticed it it's just
it's i don't know
i i try to avoid i guess thinking about
it okay
you're about to have a house full of
three little kids
and i want you to be as plugged in as
you can how long you all been together
nine years oh gosh so this is going to
be like losing a leg in an arm and part
of your lungs right yes it is
you're worth somebody that will love you
through all of it
yeah
you're right please please don't bring
these three kids into your house and
four months later send them back so that
you can be with somebody
no that's not happening you promise
i promise okay
awesome
and if you look around and say los
angeles is too freaking expensive move
to tennessee or to texas we'd love to
have you here
it's much cheaper
we'll pay you good too and there's no
state income tax you can keep all your
own money it's awesome
it's like a glitch in the matrix
cool
cool
i am so proud of you and at the same
time heartbroken for you
because i think this guy's probably a
good guy i really do and i think he
says whoa i'm not ready to be a dad of
three little kids
and
which makes here's where the we take
separate roads in the woods and that's
that's just hard
i'm so sorry
have the conversation
this week
yeah i will promise
yes
not by text daisy
no not by the way in person no yelling
no drama
let's just find out where we are because
i'm about to bring three kids home and
if we're not together then cool
um we're not gonna hook up anymore we're
not gonna do dinners anymore we're gonna
take a break for six nine months and
then we can catch up later i i'll always
love you hope you're doing well and you
need to move on with your life if he
hasn't already
yeah and you too oh i'm so sorry
but i will say this
in a world full of people who think
bravery is
putting mean posts on the internet or
creating cool tick tock videos with
rants in them
bravery looks like a 26 year old
accountant
who's highly successful
who says i'm not letting those three
kids who are got my blood pulsing
through their veins going to the system
i'm gonna figure this out
i'm gonna bring him home even though i
don't know what i'm doing even though
this is not how i drew my life up even
though
it's not not i didn't create this mess
but it landed in my lap
because these kids deserve better
that's bravery
make sure you get the care you need make
sure you get the
mental health resources that you need
make sure you got friends in your corner
make sure you got a group of people at a
local church you can lean on you whoever
you got a gang
make sure that you're going for walks
take care of yourself that you're
figuring out ways that you can sleep
your life's gonna be pretty chaotic for
a while make sure you're meeting with
the teachers of the schools and the
counselors of the schools they can give
you the resources
go all in
and i hope hope hope this guy stands up
and walks alongside you